Nicki Minaj and cardi B's feud is
heating up serena williams demands an
apology after losing the US Open women's
finals and John Legend makes history
earning egit status hey guys this is the
daily Dani and today clearly the ladies
are taking over I'm Hallie Steven and
I'm Courtney tez and now let's go ahead
and kick things off with the big fight
at New York Fashion Week that is now
gone by roll between Queen Nicki Minaj
and Empress card Eevee
an ET eyewitness claims that cardi tried
to kick and punch Nikki at a Harper's
Bazaar party before security stepped in
to create a barrier between the two
rappers party made bloody moves when she
threw her red shoe at Minaj and was
escorted out of the party
this feud does not seem to be ending
anytime soon the internet went wild
after photos surfaced of cardi with a
huge bump on her head she later took to
Instagram to explain what prompted the
fight quote I let you sneak diss me I
let you lie on me I let you attempt to
stop my bags but when you mentioned my
child you choose to like comments about
me as a mother make comments about my
abilities to take care of my daughter is
when all bets are off okay so basically
cardi is telling and Nicki to be careful
when it comes to her family and I
definitely think that was a low blow to
talk about someone's child do we even
think this fight is necessary no like I
hate fighting and it makes me so sad to
see these really strong talented women
going after each other so publicly but I
think the real question Courtney is
where is her shoe Barney buddy shoe it's
definitely uneven I think so too
I'm gonna be betting for that let me
tell you we're all trying to get a piece
of cardi B shoe but even though she left
with a knot on her head Nikki kept
things really cool after the brawl she
in true Nikki fashion says a lot on
Queen radio on Monday I would never
discuss any one's child and it's so sad
that for someone to pin that on me I
would never talk about anyone's child or
parenting I don't care about anyone's
parenting I don't give a [ __ ] and it's
so crazy to me
that people always need to make onika
the bad guy if you're right in whatever
you're doing you don't ever have to make
someone into the bad guy I just want to
let the world know that Oney Catania
Mirage would never has never and will
never speak
of anyone's child I am NOT a clown
that's clown and what is the other thing
that's clown is telling or is telling
the world that someone said something
just so that you don't feel dumb for
looking dumb for doing dumb from a rap
war to a war of words on the tennis
court Serena Williams made headlines
when she erupted over a call made by the
umpire take a look well that point
actually cost serrated the match against
20 year old Naomi Osaka from Japan it
was a tough loss for Serena but a really
big win for Naomi who finally beat her
childhood idol it's a big deal is really
huge everyone online was sympathizing
with Serena and they felt like she was
also showing a little bit of poor
sportsmanship I don't know what did you
think about that clip though I mean I
love Serena and I'm all for speaking out
when you feel like you've been wronged
but I really feel for Naomi I mean she
was the first tennis player from Japan
to win a Grand Slam singles tournament
that is a big deal and it seems like her
big magical moment was overshadowed by
Serena's reaction yeah you can never
really get that moment back your first I
mean I sympathize with her as well but
Naomi actually talked about the big
reaction of the crowd booing her when
she stopped by The Today Show take a
look well I don't know I just felt like
everyone was sort of unhappy up there
and I know that it wasn't really like
the ending wasn't how people wanted it
to be I know that in my dreams I won
like in a very tough competitive match
so it I don't know I just felt very
emotional and I felt like I had to
apologize an emotional weekend for Naomi
and for John Legend who became the first
black man to reach he got status he now
has an Emmy a Grammy an Oscar and a Tony
under his belt oh my god so many awards
and we're super proud of John I actually
had a chance to talk to him backstage at
the creative arts Emmy where
talked about his performance and
bringing home the gold in Jesus Christ
Superstar I'm so stoked for you right
now this has to feel like a top five
moment for you now having the II got
status how are you feeling in this
moment it's kind of surreal it's
something I never even thought about
like you know when I started my career I
probably want to win some Grammys and
sell a lot of Records and all that
started happening pretty quickly but I
never dreamed that I would be here
winning an Emmy and being in that rare
group of people that have won all four
of these major Academy Awards it's such
a huge honor and I'm just happy I was
part of such a great show very emotional
and she tweeted it out that she was
gonna uh Glee cry in the crowd and she
definitely did that but she also tweeted
a while ago now she has to move her
Spike TV award we will make room we have
a plenty of room at the house we'll make
room for all the trophies so they
definitely made room and it looks like
they found the perfect spot Crissy
posted this Instagram video of John
putting his Emmy on the Shelf super cute
of course Chrissy didn't miss a moment
in the caption to poke fun at her hubby
she captioned the clip with lyrics to
the arthur theme song and i say hey what
a wonderful kind today I just love them
I mean honestly any chance to get you
singing that was thank you yes I didn't
even know that that was the Arthur theme
song but I love that she always played
like pokes fun at him and says he looks
like Arthur I just think that they're
the cutest couple and that they don't
take life too seriously never take life
too serious when he's a member of the II
got club all right yeah no no Chrissy
always finds a way to humble him and she
actually deserves an award of her own
best wife award so Chrissy moved
mountains to support her man at his
milestone moment and here's what he told
me she did Chrissy got very emotional
what does it mean to have her with you
here tonight well she was supposed to be
taping lip-sync battle while we were
here and she convinced her producers to
push the second show back so she could
come here in between shows and see if we
would win this II got and I was hoping
that I would not disappoint her and make
her trip a waste of time
so she was very supportive and I'm glad
we made it worth her while I think John
and Chrissy just broke the cuteness
meter as usual and her ugly cry she was
so happy for him her ugly cry is not
even fair it was actually super pretty
and that's not fair for the rest of our
faces but look out what's good going on
with Nikki and cardi I don't feel like
this feud is gonna be over anytime soon
but if you guys are just as interested
as we are in this fight go ahead and
head over to et online we have a full
breakdown of Nikki's famous feuds and
also guys head on into the comments and
let us know if your team Nikki or if
your team cardi we're gonna leave it up
to you guys leave your comments below
and we will see you guys tomorrow
[Music]